اجرى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
مباحثات هاتفيه منفصله مع كل من غير روسي
فلادر بوتين والاكراني فولو دي ميرسي بشان
قضايا ذات الصله بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
واكد اردوغان ان اللقاءات بين مسؤوليه
المخابرات الروسيه والامريكيه في تركيا
ستلعب دورا رئيسيا في منع التصعيد في
الميدان وفي موسكو قلم متحدث باسم الكريم
ان الحوار مع الغرب يمكن ان يصبح عنصرا
قويا في المفاوضات بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لان كيف تنفذ توجيهات الغرب بدقه تعبيره
من جانبه قال رئيس دينيسكي مع رئيس التركي
اضاف انه اكد للرئيس التركيه انه اوكرانيا
ستظل ضامنا الاستقرار الغذائي العالمي
وكان نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه اليبس قد
رفض الافصاحه عن تفاصيل الاجتماع الذي عقد
في انقره بين مديريه المخابرات الروسيه
والامريكيه وقال ان هذه تفاصيل ليست للنشر
ولم يستبعد دير في اجراء اتصالات جديده
على مستوى اعلى اذا ما ابدل الامريكيون
رغبه في ذلك
معنى من انقر مراسله الجزيره فرح زمان
شوقي فرح زمان تفاصيل اكثر حول ما تم
الحديث عن هناك حول هذه الاتصالين
المنفصلين وعلى ماذا تعول تركيا لاحياء
المسار الدبلوماسي
وسيله في الحقيقه يبدو ان تركيا تؤسس
لمرحله تفاهمات جديده الاتصال الهاتفي بين
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ونظيره
الاوكراني اشاد فيه بدايه
بموافقه اوكرانيا على تمديد صفقه الحبوب
لاربعه اشهر اخرى واكد فيه على ان هذا
الامر سيقف في وجهي تداعيات جديده لازمه
غذاء عالميه يؤكد هنا على ان هذا الامر
صفقه الحبوب الى جانب صفقه تبادل الاسرى
التي تمت برعايه تركيا في وقت سابق قد
تؤدي الى توسيع التفاهمات ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني انا الرئيس التركي يقول ان هذه
التفاهمات قد تؤسس لارضيه جديده لحوار
جديد حول مساله وقف اطلاق نار جزئي او
شامل طالما ان الحديث ما زال مبكرا حتى
الان عن عقد قمه على مستوى الرؤساء بين
الطرفين الروسي والاكراني على الجانب
الاخر اتصال سبقه بين الرئيسين التركي
روسي ايضا بدا بالاشاده للطرف الروسي كونه
قبل بالاستمرار بصفقه الحبوب بعد ان علقت
روسيا ومشاركتها فيها قبل همم فتره وجيزه
يؤكد هنا كذلك على المرحله المقبله مرحله
المباحثات التي يصفها بالايجابيه يؤكد
الرئيس التركي على تفاهم اخر يتعلق بمساله
امن الطاقه ويقول للرئيس بوتن بان تركيا
شرعت بالفعل باجراءتها التقنيه والفنيه
لترى امكانيه تاسيس مركز لتصدير الغاز
الروسي في منطقه راقيه النقطه البالغت
الاهميه كذلك وهي ما تتعلق بتفاهمات
امريكيه الروسيه في تركيا هذا ما جرى بحث
كذلك خلال الاتصال الهاتفي بين الرئيسين
التركي والروسي الاجتماع الذي جرى في
انقره قبل اربعه ايام من الان بين مديري
الاستخبارات الروسيه والامريكيه في تركيا
لم ترشح عنه الكثير من المعلومات لكن
المصادر الصحفيه
تؤكد بان هذا الاجتماع بحث مساله ردع
التهديدات النوويه الى جانب مساله
المعتقلين الامريكيين في روسيا اردوغان
يصف هذا الاجتماع بان من شانها بان يخفف
من التصعيد الميداني العسكري في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كل ذلك يعني بان تركيا
تحاول التاسيس للمرحله المقبله من لاعبها
دور الوسيط بين الطرفين الروسي والاكراني
من صفقه الحبوب لصفقه تبادل الاسرى الى
صفقه خاصه بالغاز والطاقه لوقف اطلاق
النار الى تفاهمات روسيه امريكيه هنا في
انقره شكرا جزيلا لك فرح الزمان شوقي
مراسلتنا من انقرح